I think it's really important to just to
get at this idea of the scapegoat
mechanism becoming less effective
because of society's concern for victims
and nobody hated so which you know
Gerard would say this our Our concern
for victims is the universal value that
now unites the world pretty much who
will you ever find
that says that you shouldn't be
concerned with victims or you know
people being Injustice right
um and Gerard says that this is really
the fruit of the revelation of the
scapegoat mechanisms we've now seen
something that we can never unsee and it
sort of LED over 2000 it led over a very
long period of time to that becoming the
the most important value in the world to
the point that there's now memetic
rivalry over who can be the best victim
because nothing is nothing confers more
status and power than becoming a good
victim it's a weird weird
um
Paradox and inversion of like the true
nature of of Christianity
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
hello everybody I am here with Luke
Bridges we've been trying to meet for
months actually and we finally were able
to meet uh he is the author of wanting
the power of memetic desire in everyday
life and an expert on Greninja and you
know he's been following what I've been
doing as well and seeing me talk about
sacrifice and Indonesia also I'm
definitely excited to see you know what
kind of insight he can bring to us so
Luke It's good to meet you hey it's a
bit about about what brought you to
thinking about uh and numeric desire
today yeah well I'm glad we finally got
to make this happen Jonathan um I've
been following your work for a while and
it was a consolation for me uh in the
dark days of the pandemic uh yeah so I
think a fundamental to Gerard is
um you know he he explained the nature
of desire in a way that I simply never
heard before and I came across his work
after I myself had underwent a complete
um revolution in my life uh in my late
20s
um a sort of a religious conversion like
a very sort of dramatic spiritual
conversion and I realized that the very
nature of it was related to my my own
desires right the nature of desires I'd
never sort of understood a Telos or
teleology to desire before and then I
realized that I I had some but I I went
most of my life totally blind to my own
desires as as most of us are right and
in many ways I still am
so Gerard's work having revolved around
desire was especially intriguing to me
and gave me some language to sort of
understand
uh humanity and and myself both and you
know fundamental to Gerard's thought in
my opinion is that human beings are
religious uh creatures even if you don't
think you are we're religious creatures
and if you don't sort of accept that
premise there's all kinds of things
about the world that you want to
understand I know that you know that but
you know this this was
um uh really uh really eye-opening to me
sort of an understanding the world and I
in my opinion what's Central to his
thought is the human desire for
Transcendence
um and Gerard articulated this his
notion of desire in a very sort of
spiritual way that human beings seek
Transcendence whether they they know
they are or not
and the notion of transcendence is right
is the thread that I think runs through
all of Gerard's work the very idea of
the scapegoat mechanism for instance
right is is a form of false
Transcendence right it's a it's a form
of people trying to you know achieve
something Beyond themselves
um and and prevent some form of
Destruction
um but it's a form of false
Transcendence so you know as as one who
had been a a striving my entire life for
something that I couldn't quite put my
my finger on Gerard helped me make sense
of of so much of the kind of uh
religious quest in search that I was on
which I didn't even quite frankly know
that I was on uh until he sort of
introduced me to some very ancient
Concepts quite frankly right like
fundamental things
um that uh at least religious Traditions
have known you know for for a very long
time
um you know especially in in Scripture
and he sort of gave me a lens to see
those things in an entirely new light
um in in some senses I was
um you know a bit arrogant in the way
that I approached the
um sort of religion of my youth you know
like reading the Bible it doesn't have
anything very interesting to say to me
um you know Augustine the hippo thought
the same thing uh when he first you know
read the Bible right it's not very in
many many cases not very beautiful
language there's some weird things going
on I was a bit similar to that and
Gerard sort of gave me a land like a
lens uh like glasses to sort of see
myself in the story and to realize that
I'm a participant in this story
um and and to sort of see the way that I
was I was part of that story so
um you know Gerard couldn't be more
relevant I think to them to the modern
world that he explained so much when it
comes to the World Grappling with false
false ways of trying to achieve
Transcendence
and is so relevant to your work I think
because Gerard was an expert at
recognizing patterns so he he recognized
patterns in human behavior he recognized
patterns and the nature of human desire
a structure to desire not specifically
memetic desire and he recognized so at
the micro level he recognized these
patterns and at the macro level he saw
that these problems of Desire manifest
themselves in patterns of conflict
rivalry and violence at the macro level
in human culture so what is What is the
relationship could you talk about this
idea the desire for Transcendence and so
what is the relationship between
memetic desire uh and and the desire for
Transcendence
so my medic desire it just if you're
hearing the word for the first time or
the term for the first time uh Gerard
sort of coined this phrase nomadic
desire
um to to say that human beings do not
create their own desires ex nihilo out
of nothing right
um desire is not our own creation uh and
there's a whole theology behind this
right we go back to sort of creation
Theology and the creation of the world
um you know I'm not the I'm not the
author of all of my own desires
um
even though you know we many of us think
that we are right a lot so
the nature of Desire because we're
social creatures because we're part of a
story uh we affect each other right and
we we affect each other's desires and
memetic desire simply means imitative
desire so we imitate the desires of
other people
as part of the social process so desire
is formed through this this highly
social process through rituals through
the culture that we're part of uh and
especially through
um specific people or groups that have a
special importance to us that that act
as models or mediators of our desire so
you know if you grew up
um in a in a strong uh religious
Christian home some of your models of
Desire might be the Saints if you grew
up in other kinds of communities every
kind of community has certain models of
Desire these are people that are sort of
held up as exemplars they're bind people
together in sports right there might be
some really great professional athletes
that act as models of Desire so models
of Desire help help inform our own
desires and give shape to those desires
whether we know it or not and we we
usually don't know that this process is
is happening but the reason that models
of Desire affect us the reason that
they're
that they have some power over us in the
first place according to Gerard is
because we are seeking a sense of
transcendence and we we're looking for a
higher level of being right some to move
into some higher level of reality and we
we look to people that model various
desires to us as maybe possessing some
quality of being that we lack right
um some some quality of being that we
lack and we sort of enter into their
orbit For Better or Worse right this can
work in positive ways or negative ways
um I can think of all kinds of positive
examples of entering into the orbit of
somebody who's modeling that desire for
something like good and Noble but very
often we sort of look to our right and
our left and we find somebody that
appears to have some quality of being or
some higher level of being that that we
seek and they become models of desire
for us in some in some way
um it seems to become extremely true in
the world of influencers like the
YouTube Instagram type influencer where
in some ways the person is really just
does become a focus of Desire they they
just buy a bunch of stuff they wear a
bunch of clothes they they it's not
actually a quality that is
they don't seem to have virtues they
just seem to actually be desire holes
like like vortexes of Desire that are
celebrated because they're able to we
can live our our excessive desires kind
of through them something like that it's
very odd yeah so it's the influencer
it's the model that has the power over
us it's not the it's not the objects
themselves right it's like the
definition of the medic desire is that
the choice of the objects that we're
fascinated with uh come from the model
and not from the objects themselves
right not from any objective qualities
of the objects they're just imbued with
some kind of symbolic magical quality
because of whoever our model of Desire
is right like what's what's a a watch
other than some kind of Talisman of some
kind of you know weird status that every
man over a certain age that works on
Wall Street wears like one of six
different types of watches that all
happen to be in the magazines that you
see at Hudson News and airports there
they're symbolic these things are
literally symbols of some kind of
quality of being or something like that
right so these models have have is are
what's powerful for us not the objects
themselves and this creates problems a
lot of problems because we have a
love-hate relationship with anybody
who's a model of of desire for us
because those those same people act as
obstacles to us right because then we
start competing with them for the same
things and measuring everything that we
do according to the models so you know
this this leads to rivalry right this is
a huge part of Gerard's Theory it's that
memetic desire the fact that our desires
are formed in this through the social
process with other people it leads to
conflict and and to rivalry and some
really weird things right like Gerard
said one time yeah I think the reason
that we talk about Envy so much is that
nobody wants to talk about sex right
like Envy is the form in which memetic
desire takes in in the modern world and
then you have somebody like
um like in Montero we see there's some
line where he says I want to F the ones
I envy yeah right so you know this crude
way that that that's literally like
Gerard like gerardian most gerardian
statement that he could possibly make
because the reason that he wants to have
sex with the person he envies the person
that he envies is somehow a model of
desire for him and through that act
you're somehow achieving uh some some
some form of equality with the being of
the model right yes so integration
you're like integrated to them or joined
with them somehow yeah yeah so so we
have a love-hate relationship with
models that leads to rivalry um
ultimately misery and then on the macro
level that plays out in in very strange
ways in our society as well
um which is a whole another part of
Gerard's Theory but going back I mean I
I this all has to do with Transcendence
in my opinion this this human desire to
sort of go go beyond their current level
level of being and there are sort of
vertical form of transcendence which are
found you know really in mostly in
religion spirituality and then there are
what I would call sort of horizontal
forms of transcendence where we try to
find Transcendence and all kinds of of
strange ways right like through just
trans shape shifting and Transforming
Our identity and changing jobs and
looking for it in all the wrong places
basically yeah yeah and so so the
vertical transformation the vertical
call for Transit could account also for
things like generals let's say Alexander
or people who inspired
their men to be have certain qualities
and so it's not all positive but it it
would you know he would appear as
someone who kind of Drew people's desire
into him and they would see him as an
example but also someone to impress
someone to outdo all of this all this
kind of happening imagine it in sports
you see you can see that quite clearly
as well in terms of the relationship
between players within a team and then
with the other team how those things
play out in terms of of the medic desire
yeah I mean a sports team that kind of
loses some uh
that loses some kind of transcendent
purpose like some kind of like Telos
like outside of the team itself
just lock up the locker room just
evolves very very quickly right you sort
of like forget what it is that you're
that you're doing
um and I guess that's why like I don't
know like why some players or teams that
um win all of the time uh like what
what's what's next in the teleology for
that team
like what what happens next right and
that's usually why people don't stay on
top for very long
um because you can only sort of go so
far and if you're seeking like what's
next right yeah I don't know you win the
Super Bowl three times in a row what can
you possibly do I don't know Tom Brady
goes to the Hall of Fame like at some
point he's sort of exhausts it's its
purpose for exhausted by the category of
the sport itself it's like you know like
now we're gonna go like take over a
country no that doesn't work like it's
like you reach the limit and then it's
held in by that very category yeah so it
happens in sports teams it this happens
within companies all of the time
um you know I think uh you know we live
in a world where there's a hierarchy of
of values there's a hierarchy of being
um again this is a very ancient uh
religious concept right
um and I think modern in the modern
world people that reject that idea
um do all kinds of weird things that end
up resulting in more conflict and not
less right they do things in the name of
um in the name of progress that actually
uh increase conflict right so to give
you an example right like if there's a
hierarchy if we live in a hierarchical
world and people are sort of looking
into other people as as models of Desire
by the way it's very important for a
culture to have like positive like
models period but especially positive
models
um so there's like a weird thing happens
right like one of the stories I talk
about in the book is you know zappos.com
decided to like move from a more
traditional management structure which
you know they have their problems right
I'm not I'm not a fan of bureaucracy or
anything like that to just totally
collapsing
the entire hierarchy overnight turned
everybody that worked there into like
very confused and in total crisis mode
and Chaos because they literally
collapsed their entire hierarchy almost
overnight I don't think that they
understood
um that's the sort of the nature of
reality itself is hierarchical and if
you're going to collapse it visibly what
happens is that an invisible hierarchy
sort of develops under the surface
that's becomes like a dragon you don't
even know it's there you don't even know
how it operates right and something is
something similar has happened happening
with the Sexes where we sort of like uh
not necessarily collapsing hierarchy but
but collapsing difference right like
collapsing difference and not admitting
of complementarity not admitting just
fundamental things it leads to a
situation where people are trying to
Recon constitute some form of hierarchy
in all kinds of different different ways
because we we have like a need to do
that yeah and you end up having both
confused identities you have these
confused kind of uh gender roles and
gender identities but you also have
hyper versions of extremes you know I
pointed this out to someone recently you
know you people think that it's only the
this kind of uh leveling of gender only
leads to you know let's say all the
letters and and all this kind of
fluidity but it also leads to you know
hyper masculinity and the kind of hyper
sexualized masculinity and
hypersexualized femininity the types of
characters you see in media today like
this kind of hyper male and let's say
kind of horror woman something that
would never would never have been public
in the world you know for thousands of
years you never would have seen these
kind of characters paraded out in public
but now it's become completely normal to
see these hypersexualized beings uh you
know in hyper-gendered beings in ways
that are that are that are very
surprising and at the same time watching
everything become fluid and break down
in terms of identity at the same time
it's like you need a proper like you
said proper hierarchy that leads to
some kind of real Transcendence
right yeah so I I've you know I had a
big part of Gerard's thinking it does
have to do with sacrifice and that's
kind of what I would call the societal
macro Community level
um pattern that he recognized right
something that happens at the community
level
because when when a person when anybody
is seeking Transcendence there's sort of
something that has to die in order for
them to achieve this sort of uh
different quality of being that they're
that they're looking for right so that
happens at the individual level
but it can also happen kind of at the
societal level and you know I've
listened to your your kind of theory on
sacrifice
um I know you mentioned Gerard in it but
I'm just curious as to you know do you
think that Gerard's sort of idea of the
scapegoat mechanism squares of what
you're saying
um or do you do you think it's sort of
just like a subset of a larger kind of
theory of sacrifice that's what I I
think but I mean maybe you can help you
understand it better for me to change my
mind I'd be fine with changing my mind
but it seems when I look at sacrifice
what I see the Yom Kippur sacrifice is
probably the best version of a sacrifice
because it's an atonement sacrifice it's
an you know it's an at one minute
sacrifice it's the the sacrifice that
makes us one and it has two sacrifices
as part of it there is on the one hand
the scapegoat sacrifice literally where
you take a goat you put all your all
your evil on it and you kind of kick it
out you abuse it whatever and then it
falls off a cliff or it runs into the
desert to to be become food for the
demon but then you also have uh another
sacrifice which is the pure animal which
is sacrificed up towards God
uh and what I see in sacrifice at least
in scripture is those two types of
sacrifices one which we could be called
a scapegoat sacrifice and you see it in
a lot of cultures you're right
sacrificing
a prisoner sacrificing uh you know you
see they did it even all the way up to
Roman times when they would have uh
people fight in their in the Arenas it
was basically a human sacrifice of their
cap their captives in order to kind of
manifest the glory of Rome and and doing
it but then you also have
a sacrifice which I would call a
vertical sacrifice which is giving the
best up and and you give the best up and
then that constant that is part of what
constitutes the the body and I've talked
about it like let's say in terms of
sports team on the one hand you you do
have to scapegoat in the sense that you
can't let anybody into your your sports
team right you have to eliminate
behaviors and players that don't fit
into the team that's necessary
um but then you also need to give your
intention and your and your will and
your best up towards the goal of what
you're doing so that's what I see these
two and so I don't know if Gerard
accounts for them with his scapegoat
sacrifice or if he has two theories or I
don't know yeah I don't think there's
any conflict between what Gerard is
saying and kind of what I've what I've
heard you articulate which is just it's
simply like the Bro a broader view of
sacrifice I don't think Gerard I think
he he identified a very particular kind
of sacrifice and I agree with you that
there's all kinds of other sacrifices
that don't necessarily fit into the
pattern of the scapegoat uh mechanism
necessarily it's like for sure
identifying that has been amazing I
think it's been really yeah do you
understand Christianity but then also to
understand the 20th century and to
understand a lot of the things that that
we went through you know uh as
Christianity kind of started collapsing
as well have you thought as did Gerard
talk about because one of the things
that we say we myself and also the
people at uh Lord of spirits as we say
you know Christ is both goats it is in
the Yom Kippur sacrifice Christ seems to
be both the sacrifice of the the one who
accepts to be the sacrifice of the
stranger outside the city who takes on
the sins who accepts the blame all of
that but then he also is something like
the sacrifice of the firstborn and the
sacrifice of the firstborn even in
scripture is not the same as the
scapegoat sacrifice
so I don't I don't know like I also
don't know if your art accounts for that
idea like when when Abraham is going to
sacrifice Isaac
it's not a scapegoat sacrifice he's he's
supposed to offer his best up to God
um
and so I don't know yeah these are
things that I that I that I think about
but I'm not an I don't know Gerard well
enough to to be able to
yeah well I want to go back to you your
idea of what I like sort of horizontal
and vertical
sacrificing up triggered an idea so I
want to get but what you're saying now
brings um brings up questions like
atonement theology that are super
complex and we don't need to necessarily
get into those right now but there is an
idea I think you have to be careful that
there is one conception of of you know
Christ's sacrifice on the cross sort of
you know God needing some kind of blood
sacrifice right yeah
no I don't like that either do I right
and Gerard in his earlier days was sort
of implying that and then he befriended
this old um priest uh I shouldn't call
him old I don't know how old they were
when he met but in in Austria father
Raymond schwager who sort of helped
Gerard understand the theological
implications of what he was saying and
um I mean I come from just a very old
tradition of Augustine and Aquinas and
Gregory of Nissa and irenaeus and my
understanding is that you know God could
have achieved the salvation of the world
in in many many different ways right it
needed not be that particular way but
this was a sacrifice of love right and
in some senses it was this the most
perfect uh sort of way but but needed
not be that right so in other words it's
not like we you know we chose to like
affect what we thought was going to be
yet one more effective scapegoat
mechanism like right and yet it the
whole thing was subverted by by the set
by the sacrifice of Christ on the cross
because there was the the Holy Spirit
sort of enlightened the the minds after
the resurrection of a very very small
group of Christians that for the very
first time sort of saw the mechanism
that was taking place and saw like what
we had brought on ourselves so there's a
big difference by us sort of uh being
responsible for the violence and God
being responsible for the violence right
big big difference right so it was the
it's the revelation
that we had so God gave the Revelation
for us to be able to see the scapegoat
mechanism in its fullness
for the first time through the
crucifixion it's not the first time that
it was ever
um there were never hints of it I mean
the Old Testament is full of the story
of Joseph and his brothers gives us a
perspective of what's going on that
there's really no comparable for in any
other kind of literature like we see
that Joseph is in innocent and sort of
the victim of the scapegoating through
the whole story it's almost like we we
have the um the director's cut from the
standpoint of the Joseph or something
right and we know that he's not
responsible for that yeah
yeah
but there's it's hard to sacrifice is
one of the hardest things to think about
by the way to be honest it is so
difficult to think about because in some
ways so primordial and so encompassing
but
so what one of the things you see I
think this is my my perception also of
what Christ is doing one of the things
he's doing is that
by willingly becoming
someone's scapegoat you could say he's
almost he's kind of flipping or joining
the two sacrifices together where by be
by in his willingness to die
for others you could say he's turning
the skateboard sacrifice into something
like the the sacrifice of good odor
right this idea of like of the best
which is given up
um and the reason also why I think that
that's happening is because then you see
that pattern modeled in in uh the early
Christian Martyrs where the martyrs are
basically saying
I'll be your scapegoat
and then that scapegoat will become like
a a sacrifice of worship up to God and
it's going to secretly change you
without you even knowing what's going on
it's like if I if I do that and I don't
like I tell people like I don't want to
do that like I don't want to die I don't
want to I don't want people to kill me
I'm not but but I can see it that that
seems to be what's going on it's like
there's a mechanism it really is like a
mechanism where
self-sacrifice seems to be the place
where these two sacrifices get joined
and it's like a refounding of reality if
you do it properly I think that's I
think that's right and that's um
there's it this the idea of self
self-sacrifice is the key to I think
understanding right like Christianity
um and and what's happening in in the
Liturgy as well
so um God willing you you or I will not
have to become red Martyrs blood Martyrs
and physically uh who knows um yeah and
and you know give up our bodies and
blood but there's what what's happening
in the Christian liturgy in Orthodox and
in the web is is a
participation in that self-sacrificial
act on the cross right so it's got what
they you know the early church called
the white martyrdom or you know it's
it's a it's still a form of dying to
yourself and self-sacrifice that you
know if you're if you really understand
what's happening you're sort of uniting
your self-sacrifice to Christ's
self-sacrifice on the cross and it's all
being offered offered you know um and
there's something really beautiful about
that and and remembering part of a
liturgy is animesis it's a remembrance
of of you know what is what has happened
right it only had to happen once right
it doesn't mean that we can't predict
continue to participate in it but it's a
remembrance of that singular event
um and also very importantly a
remembrance of I mean this is why you
know Good Friday is so important and I
always for me it's always like one of
the most I mean solemn and Powerful sort
of liturgies of the year because it's a
remembrance of
um of the scapegoat mechanism and what
the pattern of human behavior it's
almost as if we we keep we default back
to the old rights to the old sacrificial
rights that involve not self-sacrifice
but sacrifice of other people to
preserve ourselves so sacrif there's a
there's an element of like
self-preservation
in sacrifice yeah of course
huge element of to protect protect
myself and it's if that's like my
default motive being then I will
inevitably sacrifice somebody else at
the altar of my of myself so there's an
an aspect of remembering our our
tendency to engage in that kind of
behavior and then to see I mean every
week or every day right to to see
actually how that's been completely
transformed into an act that can be an
act of love
and does I'm I've been curious about
this does Gerard talk about the eating
part of sacrifice does he address that
in his theory or did he just talk about
the killing part let's say in terms of
sacrifice because of course this we
don't eat the scapegoat nobody eats a
scapegoat but you eat
other sacred like the sacrifice up you
tend to eat it it's part of the part of
the sacrifice that you offer it to God
but then you it becomes your body as
well so so in the the Hebrew sacrifices
you would give the meat up and then you
would eat it
um or in the Greek sacrifices that joke
about how you know they would offer up
the bones they tricked the gods and then
they would eat the meat you know but but
I don't know if Gerard talks about the
the eating part he he in in terms of
like like consuming the the very like
being of the other person like in in the
act of he he not a lot I think that it's
in violence in the sacred
um his book from the 70s
um you know orphic religions or orphism
um was sort of founded on his premise of
um you know Dionysus right being like
ripped apart and eaten by the Titans and
you know that that
form the basis of a lot of Cults for
them I just wrote an article just a few
weeks ago about the cultural fashion
fascination with cannibalism like what
yeah right now it's like what the hell
is going on with that right there's a
movie with Timothy Timothy chalamet
coming out where he's like this teenage
cannibal who's on this like love
Adventure across the country I haven't
seen it I don't think it's out in
theaters yet but I I saw the premiere
for that and I was like wow there's been
like a lot of movies about cannibalism
like like Jeffrey Dahmer on Netflix like
what's going on there are like are
people somehow like
I don't know right like somehow
fascinated by this idea I think they are
I think I think it's definitely
happening and it's not just movies and
TV it's it's the idea of also the idea
of growing your own meat like you saw a
lot of that but like for some reason
they're always talking about how you
could grow your own meat like you could
grow your own flesh and you could eat
yourself let's say it has to do with it
has to do with like cell causation and
this problem of it all of these types of
symbolism like incest cannibalism
they're all related because they're
about they're and sodomy as well I'm
afraid so had to do with like
self-causation it's like it's it's not
normal
normal uh procession of being it's like
a
a circular type of causation right
that's why it has to do with clowns and
Carnival and then others and and all of
that stuff is all related so it's not
surprising that cannibalism will appear
and so also will more and more just the
idea of suicide as a um as a normal part
of reality the idea of self-killing
self-creation self-identification all
these things are all related to this
kind of circular causality yeah yeah and
and suicide um not to go off on a
tangent but there's a very memetic
quality to suicides as well right like
the the imitation of a desire that one
may have not uh had before it's it's
it's modeled and actually
carried out in some way um you know
there's probably something to be said
about school shootings and it the point
is violence whether it's violence to
oneself or violence to others
according to Gerard is one of the most
memetic kinds of behaviors right it's
mimetic contagion it's it's contagious
right this this desire for
self-preservation or the desire to from
Vengeance these things have some kind of
of a memetic quality to them
uh before I forget you know this this
point that you made about some like the
sort of noble I'll call it the noble
sacrifice of the best right that form of
sacrifice
um as I read Gerard the way that he
describes the scapegoat mechanism
happening
it can happen in sort of into in two
forms right one of them one is just pure
self-preservation
um of of a community needing to having
um decomposed
uh and needing to reconstitute itself
through this false Transcendence that it
tries to achieve through singling out
the cancer at usually in the form of a
person or a group of people which it
expels or eliminates
um
interestingly enough
there's there's often a
sacrifice only works if the person being
sacrificed is not too strange right
there has to be some similarity to the
people that are that are doing the
scapegoating
so in ancient cultures you had
um you know if an animal was going to be
sacrificed
that animal would need to be dressed up
like a human would need to be fed human
things and sort of integrated into the
community before it worked so there was
like a kindredness before it worked as
an effective sacrifice
um this by the way this is Gerard's sort
of like weird theory about the domestic
how the domestication of animals
happened right like dogs and and cats
since they were literally used for Human
Sacrifice but they had to be
domesticated first
or else the sacrifice wasn't as
effective so there's there's something
sort of weird about that they're
different
they're different species different
creature yet we have to sort of see
ourselves in them in some way for the
sacrifice enough yeah enough for you to
recognize what you're doing let's say
because it's like you sacrifice a flower
and you know it has no it has no
connection with you you know although
you could offer flowers though you could
offer them up but not that kind of
scapegoat sacrifice that's for sure no
so so that the idea of similarity is
really important in Gerard so the two
the two concepts of similarity and
proximity right right views are these
are what really trigger a memetic crisis
and eventually the scapegoat mechanism
so
um as you know like the the symbolism of
the twins is really important and and
Gerard you know it's really weird in
almost every culture in the world you
have a myth where there are twins
usually identical twins that one of them
ends up killing the other one or they
end up committing violence against one
another right in the Book of Genesis I
believe there are five stories of
sibling rivalry alone in the book in the
just in the Book of Genesis King kills
Abel founds a city right then you have
uh Joseph and his brothers you have
Jacob and Esau and you've got who are
twins like clearly like the clear twins
that is a explicit one yeah yeah that's
the explicit one so the similarity seems
to breed conflict right
um there's a
um there it leads more easily to a
conflict of Desire or the desire to
differentiate one one self Romulus and
Remus right the founders of Rome they're
these mythological uh Twins and there's
not enough room for the both of them so
that leads to conflict and then
proximity right proximity so again twins
are in close proximity to one another
these are what Gerard calls internal
mediators of desire right internal
meaning that they're inside of my world
so the scapegoat mechanism only happens
with people that are in close proximity
to each other right like like within the
community that's part of why the
sacrificed animal needed to sort of
become more
um alike right it needed to become
internal to the community so he wouldn't
have seen for example the killing of
foreign captors a foreign foreign
prisoners as a scapegoat mechanism
because that seems to be a universal
practice too it's like you you win a war
you catch a bunch of people then you
ceremoniously murder some of them
publicly in order to make a point about
you know about your nation and about
your strength you know up and against
another another group let's say
um I don't know if you would have I
don't know if you would have said that
but that doesn't seem to be effective
anymore right I mean and then that could
be because
um
maybe maybe at one point that was
effective but it doesn't seem effective
anymore when that's when that's
happening maybe it's because it's not
visible or something like that
um and this is part of Gerard's whole
thesis is that the scapegoat mechanism
is becoming less and less effective
right it doesn't work any anymore the
way that it used to before it was sort
of revealed to to humanity and the
concern for victims prevents the
scapegoat mechanism like our eyes are
somehow opened to to the victim and that
is a direct result of sort of what's
been shown to us in in the Revelation
really in the in the scriptures and it
makes the scapegoat mechanism less less
effective so we need we either need more
of them we need we need them more often
and they simply don't work to bind
people together I guess in extraordinary
cases the scapegoat mechanism has worked
to bind the world together you could
argue that the Holocaust
um you know in in some sense did that
and like we we're all United in this
belief like this can never happen again
yeah
um but I've actually argued that that
that Hiroshima was a human sacrifice in
the sense that Americans said clearly we
have to kill these innocent people in
order to stop the war we have to kill
these tens of thousands of innocent
people and in once in one shot uh and if
we do that then we'll get a blessing
from heaven like we will we will end the
war
um because it they weren't killing
soldiers and it wasn't it was like a
gamble almost it really was it was very
similar to the cliche of how people
think Human Sacrifice used to happen
right it's like you know if I kill this
person you know then then the rain will
come or something like that and it was
like that's what Hiroshima and Nagasaki
were I think
yeah those are what a calculated human
sacrifice in the sense that we knew that
innocent lives were going to be lost but
not knowing the future just
hoping that there was some kind of a I
don't know would you say it was like a
binding
force or just pure like deterrent and
fear
I think it was also a binding a binding
Force I think it it for sure it it
created I think the United States in
like the United States is born in
Hiroshima in some ways uh in terms of
what it would become because it's like
the the radical action
and the the result of it let's say
ending the war this kind of terrible
thing terrible
terrible action at the outset
uh it seemed to be a kind of founding I
think uh for America you know leading
into the the next phase of their
existence so but I don't know like like
I said that's my intuition in terms of
watching it well I I think I think the
intuition is is I think is right in the
sense that Gerard said that every
culture is founded on some on a founding
murder yeah so so culture is is always
founded on some violent act it's it's
why culture emerges as
um the ritualized like like rituals and
culture are in institutions arise to
prevent the violence of the founding
murder from happening again and in that
sense I sort of see it's not like
America's only had one culture I think
we've had like
a special culture since World War II
yeah and and like maybe that I'm just
talking out loud here I've never thought
about this but like maybe that's the
founding murder of the new um post-world
War culture yeah and consensus right
that that we've had right these these
founding murders and yeah there's a few
secret scandals in World War II that we
can't that nobody thinks about because
they become they kind of landed so deep
in in our psyche the other example is
that we always said we won the war but
you know we never say that it was
actually the Russians
and greatly that run the war and those
Russians we basically shook the hand
with the devil in order to beat Hitler
and now because of that
communism gets a soft play in the United
States and people always wonder like why
is it people are so soft on communism
it's a very very deep deep mythological
reason it's because we come our society
is based on a very deep compromise in
which we gave half of Europe to an evil
empire in order to stop the war so it's
like there are these really deep sins
that are at the origin of our of our
civilization that that we can't see
people kind of can't see them but I know
that and that's not necessarily
sacrifice but it's like a weird sin
that's at the origin of things well I
think I think it's very related right I
mean Gerard's magnum opus is called
things hidden since the foundation of
the world these are the things that we
don't want to admit about about Humanity
about our own
um violence in Christian terms you could
say sinfulness right about about our own
weakness and frailty the denial of death
all these things there's these these
things hidden since the foundation of
the world are our own propensity to
murder and cover cover up and and and to
cover up these things under rituals
under institutions right there's all
kinds of like rituals in the world that
are really um for the sole purpose of
preventing violence right it's like a
very important part of Gerard's theory
is like there's there's an initial Act
of the scapegoat mechanism that happened
at some point and then it's re it's it's
ritualized after that right in the form
of of rituals right so companies can
have these rituals like a lot of sports
I think developed right especially like
in the Roman Coliseum like developed as
rituals to prevent the spread of more
violence yeah it wasn't the scapegoat
mechanism is always about stopping the
spread of more violence right so
Gerard's line Satan casts out Satan it's
like I need to do a little bit of
violence in order to prevent
a lot of violence yeah which is a
dangerous way to think right it's this
like very sort of calculating way to
think I think it's terrible ethics
doesn't account for the Dignity of the
human person there's all kinds of
problems but Gerard is saying that
that's this is the pattern that Humanity
constantly falls back into is thinking
that we can prevent a lot of violence
through targeted violence through making
scapegoats but we always need to find
another one that's the cycle that you
know Christ stopped right by becoming
willingly the the scapegoat because some
of the imagery in the story of Christ
definitely has to do with this in the
sense that even in many of the church
fathers they'll often say or in the
hymnography we hear
you know how the world is Created from
the side from Christ's side that is in
Christ being pierced you know the water
and the blood that come out is the
church it's actually the world saying
Maximus talks about the world is being
created you know while Christ is is
dying on the cross and this sense that
the world comes out of its side like Eve
comes out of Christ's side or the church
comes out of his side and so there is
there it seems like the symbolism is
carried in to Christianity but like you
said it's kind of flipped or it's it's
subverted because because it's a form of
self-sacrifice then
it's like the the civilization that gets
founded it ends up not being the Roman
civilization that pierced Christ but the
the civilization that's Christ is
secretly planting is the one that will
rise up and take over Rome ultimately
um never completely but at least enough
for the for for the transformation to be
to be real yeah and that symbolism the
symbolism that you're describing like
you know the blood and water that
flipped from the side the Eucharist
itself is is is has all kinds of
symbolism right you're talking about
like like blood blood and and body right
and the the it itself is constituted
through a sacrificial uh act right you
have to crush grapes until they can
become so and and and and the wheat into
the breast so all of the the the
language and the symbolism of sacrifice
is uh is now non-blooding sacrifice is
Thoroughly infused in the symbolism of
of liturgy um at least the one that you
and I I think both know
um but this idea that the the victim
I think it's really important to just to
get at this idea of the scapegoat
mechanism becoming less effective
because of society's concern for victims
and nobody hated so which you know
Gerard would say this our Our concern
for victims is the universal value that
now unites the world pretty much who
will you ever find that says that you
shouldn't be concerned with victims or
you know people being Injustice right
um and Gerard says this is really the
fruit of the revelation of the scapegoat
mechanisms we've now seen something that
we can never unsee and it sort of LED
over 2000 it led over a very long period
of time to that becoming the the most
important value in the world to the
point that there's now memetic rivalry
over who can be the best victim because
nothing is nothing confers more status
and power than becoming a good victim
it's a weird weird
um
Paradox and inversion of like the true
nature of of Christianity right and so
did Gerard my understanding is that at
the end towards the end he also started
talking about the pattern of antichrist
as related to something like that
something like a kind of twisting of the
the twisting of the the recognition of
the victim into something like uh a
disturbed version of Christianity or
something well there's there's two
there's two ways out of the conundrum
that Society has got itself in according
to this is my reading of Gerard
um
so one is Nietzsche who who Gerard
thought was like the most important
philosopher
um of the last 150 years because nobody
saw so clearly
um the role of Christ who he compared to
the the Dionysus myth and Dionysus by
the way is the is the God of Insanity
and ritualized Madness who unites people
in ecstasy and drunken parties and and
blesses the the scapegoat essentially
the scapegoat mechanism and he says you
know nobody saw the what the the
Christian story was about more than
Nietzsche but he rejected it and he he
said you know the concern for victims is
slave morality and you know we need to
do away with the concern for victims and
not only that in fact victims should be
like the weak predict the protection of
it they should be sacrificed in the name
of society right achieving some higher
levels of being which indirectly led to
Nazi socialism right yeah
um so so there's the Nietzsche approach
that the concern for victims needs to be
eradicated because this is the slave
morality of Christianity or something
like that
and then on the on the flip side you
have the Antichrist and the Antichrist
is
um the way one way that I would describe
the I don't like the term but the
so-called culture wars is essentially
the culture really the secular culture
trying to be more Christian than
Christianity or more Christian than
Christ and saying we care for victims
more than
um than you Christians do right or this
is the grand Inquisitor in Dostoevsky
right like if you cared so much you know
we do a better job at caring for victims
than the church has ever done or
whatever right
um and and and so there's this weird
rivalry almost that that is in some way
the culture is like a memetic rival to
Christianity to the extent that the two
of them get in a weird uh double bind uh
memetic War it's really bad for both
especially for Christianity
um and the anti what is the Antichrist
but the one that comes along and does
the best job at that totally unites
Humanity promises peace promises to con
to be you know to have the utmost
concern for all victims to end poverty
to do to do all of those things that
Christianity promised and couldn't do so
in a sense
because of a lack of sort of
eschatological sort of understanding of
of and teleology the Antichrist replaces
Christianity by almost becoming what
those who have rejected Christ want him
to be if that makes sense yeah yeah
so there's one thing also about Gerard
which which puzzles me a little it's my
understanding it maybe you tell me if
I'm wrong but my understanding is that
he also had a sense in which this
scapegoat after being sacrificed was
also deified somehow like or was placed
in the in a in a position of of Honor
like a high position after the sacrifice
so maybe if you can talk a little bit
about that because I'm not sure I
understand like I've seen it I've
actually seen it myself I there there's
some African tribe I remember dealing
with in Congo named the Kuba tribe that
they they had they had chased the
pygmies out of their land and they had a
mask which was a pygmy mask and the
pygmy mask was something that they would
like it was one of their most sacred
objects and they would honor it but they
also would see the the pygmies as like
basically like force demons at the same
time it was like it was just this weird
thing I didn't understand
well that's a that's a huge part of his
theory and and it's it's because nobody
has the power to unite a
um a community that's embroiled in
memetic violence
which would otherwise
destroy itself right that this the they
can't save themselves and the the only
thing that will unite them together one
way to think of it the only thing they
can agree on the only desire that that
will unite them is a shared contempt for
and hatred of the scapegoat so the
scapegoat unites them together
in this act and this ritual Act of
um and by the way like the scapegoat
ritual almost always happened through a
long process of you know they would
parade the scapegoat in in Greece it's
called the pharmacos they would parade
the pharmacos through the streets
um with them
um you know mock them
um all the things that remind you of the
crucifixion by the way
um for days and it would that was
important because that's that gave the
people a sense of catharsis
um and and released all of the pent-up
memetic violence that they were aiming
at each other they can collectively aim
at the at the single scapegoat mechanism
they expel the scapegoat kill the
scapegoat do whatever horrible thing
they do to the scapegoat and then
magically magically in quotes here right
because this is the false Transcendence
there they achieved some level of
temporary peace
um and unity with each other it feels
good they that that what Aristotle
talked about that catharsis so what ends
up happening a short time later is that
they they this the scapegoat almost
always in ancient cultures comes is
worshiped they'll build a shrine over
the site where the scapegoat was killed
they'll do something like that because
the scapegoat takes on like a like a
sacred power because it's the only thing
that had the power to solve their
problem so and who outside of themselves
and that has the nature of a God or some
something that you worship some so like
a higher being that was able to somehow
solve the problem is attributed is
projected onto this the scapegoat
um in this
I I know this is a little weird for
people listening it's kind of a little
hard to understand but
um you know think about great figures in
history that like are not revered until
after they die I mean this happens like
all the time like people that were
assassinated murdered
um who begin to sort of like take on
almost sacred Aura I mean and we have
Miss uh throughout all of our stories
right in Tolkien you've got you know
Gandalf the White comes back and and
he's sort of more powerful than before
like I mean we we just this is like just
part of the the human story we have this
sort of idea in our imagination somehow
and you know this may be a controversial
statement but I think what happened most
recently maybe with the death of George
Floyd right I mean it it sort of had
this this sort of um almost there's been
like sacred connotations that have been
attached to to that to to him now yeah
um and you know I I I've seen him like
depicted as like as like Christ
you know uniting people around the world
and building shrines
um and there is a bit of that uh like
almost a process of deification
um is how Gerard would describe it right
and deification is I I think is is more
of in in sort of the Orthodox tradition
right the whole like spiritual like life
is is often described as a process of
deification
um but this is almost like a false dude
a false defecation which goes back to
the false Transcendence where the real
deification right being united and
becoming more like God
um becoming holy all of those things is
is the is a real sort of positive sense
of defecation
yeah well that I mean it's interesting
especially because a lot of people point
out in the George Floyd Story how he was
a criminal how he had done horrible
things and so in this Theory or in this
Vision it it almost serves the purpose
like it actually almost narratively and
mysteriously would function
as a way in which it would even make it
stronger that he would then ultimately
kind of unite people together and act as
this this this new angel that appears
let's say and as over over this question
and I hadn't thought about it that way
it um yeah you know I think I think
Gaddafi did the same thing to to the to
people
um you know Qaddafi you know by all
accounts was not really a a good man I
don't think he was a good leader I think
he you know it committed crimes and
um what one uh very well-known Gerard
scholar Mark onspach I like his work a
lot he said in fact it's because of
Gaddafi's
um kind of guilt
that
helped him become a better stand-in for
the guilt of everybody else if that
makes sense right this goes back to the
similarity thing right it's almost as if
because he's guilty
he he can be an easier substitute or
sacrificial victim for the guilt for the
guilt of everybody else in the country
and if you read and he was literally
lynched in the street yeah right like
these horrific images and if you read
what some of the people said
uh in Libya he the the one one guy in
particular said all of the evil has now
been purged from our country right like
in a couple of days after he died you
just can't have a more sort of textbook
example of of that happening and they
why do they have to get rid of his body
well because right away they were going
to be shrines built to it
um and they were they were they were
actually like worried about that process
of deification happening huh
huh so
here's a very difficult question
does Gerard
talk about about the manner in which
it seems at least to me that something
similar happened to Hitler
it's like the Germans were able to put
all their guilt into one person
and and to kind of absolve themselves to
it not totally but at least to some
extent and even the West in general
by by making Hitler the one evil one
evil player like the one that like the
the one person that is the cause of it
all
it seems like there's something of that
going on there like where we we just put
all the evil in him and he's still like
still today it's a he is the ultimate
Evil character the one in which all evil
kind of lands let's say
yeah the personification of of all evil
like almost standing in for taking the
place of um of a satanic figure or or
Satan himself right like there's almost
something
um
there's almost it's almost as if
Humanity
um
told us told itself a story for a
certain amount of time that like you
know we took care of
um you know Hitler ended in demise we we
took care of the problem
um you know we built these institutions
it'll never happen again we've built the
memorials and and all of the evil has
been personified in this one figure yet
the scapegoat mechanism runs rampant
throughout the world
um even still and part of the problem
with memetic violence and the scapegoat
mechanism is the diversion of attention
and I think mimesis in general has to do
with what we pay attention to and what
and what we focus on what we become
obsessed with and because the only way
that a scapegoat is made is if attention
becomes focused in a group on a single
individual through this kind of memetic
process
which diverts US in what which involves
projection which involves of all of our
shortcomings and our own violence and
our own sins onto this one person and
that it involves a process of
transference and all of those things
simply Kick the Can down the road and
don't deal with any kind of structural
problems any kind of structural sin our
own propensity to to do to do violence
right which we need to remind ourselves
of so you would you could say that
Gerard had a very augustinian or or sort
of dark uh view of of of of of human
nature and sort of against sort of
Enlightenment rationality where like oh
we just we all get like you know we just
read a lot of books and we discover
these secrets about the world and and
therefore like we can Purge violence
from our Miss it's like Stephen Pinker
101. you know what I'm saying and it's
like like not not recognizing like sort
of these ancient forces
that that are still very much at work
that now just manifest themselves in
different ways and because the ways they
manifest themselves are different
um we might not recognize them
um you know we're not usually in some
parts of the world but we're usually not
literally
um you know murdering people and
dragging them through the streets or
just doing it in in other sort of
spiritual ways often right which you
know the gospels actually talk about
that under the context of murder so you
know I think this the scapegoat
mechanism is just evolving and
transforming yeah for sure they cancel
the cancel culture that we're seeing
happening is definitely
has some of the scapegoat mechanism in
it you know the way that it that
manifests itself it's like we need to
find especially like the hunt almost
like the hunt for for someone to cancel
like we need to find the next person we
need to purge the world of of of these
these two people and if we do so and
we'll we'll find some kind of paradise
um and so then then you have the other
version which I don't which I'd like to
know what you think about that because I
mean Jordan Peterson has kind of brought
brought out this new vision of of
soldier nation's uh sold in itin's way
of seeing this which is the idea of
self-blaming you could say or of seeing
us taking the sins on ourselves uh and
that that could be the right
transformational process to actually
change the world ultimately and you see
that of course like I said in terms of
the the martyrs how they're willing to
die despite their innocence you see it
in terms of monastic practice where the
monks will take the blame on themselves
even for other people's sins that kind
of stuff which I would never do but it's
like you see it happen in monasteries
where where the the spiritual father
would like actually take the blame for
other people's uh things
um so I don't know if you if Gerard has
talked about that if you've thought
about that as well
I have thought about that and you know
that has to do with um again with
self-sacrifice and with
accepting certain um injustices that are
committed against you you know perhaps
even taking on injustices from other
people without always seeking uh
retribution which you know I think
Gerard says is the is is the satanic lie
right that the retribution or you know
the line from the gospel Satan casts out
Satan it has everything to do with that
principle right that you know that that
little bit of violence will will somehow
do good that violence can do good
um
the self-blame thing is the flip side of
that is this is something I was reading
Gerard last night and I pulled up a
quote so I think this is relevant to
what you're saying I'm just going to
read it he said since
since Christians have become aware of
their failings and charity
of their connivance with established
political orders in the past and present
world that are always sacrificial
so basically since Christians are sort
of accusing themselves of their own
failings and charity and have been part
of sacrificial political orders in the
past and even now they are particularly
vulnerable to the ongoing blackmail of
contemporary neopaganism that's a quote
from Renaissance so that's there's a lot
there right to unpack but one way that I
interpret that
is that
because it's almost like the accuser
right this ancient language of the
accuser and The Advocate and
when the accuser accuses you of your
your own sins and shortcomings and and
failings with Gerard is basically saying
like that the church the the Christian
world has has been is being accused of
all of these things and has been for a
very long time right this goes back to
you know that we we care about victims
more than Christ cares about victims
right then they're sort of uh
susceptible to the black male of
neo-paganism right which is sort of like
um
holding
um
is is the is the accusation that because
you know the history of Christianity has
not been perfect that therefore it
should cede all of the story and all of
the kind of right to to like let's just
select like a great president and he'll
solve all of our problems right or
something like that
um so there's something to be said about
this about the self-blame right because
there's a negative sort of form of that
which I think comes under the which
comes from the accuser yeah that's
self-blame is different because it's a
weaponized it's like weaponized
compassion you know I've talked about
this recently in terms of uh in terms of
if you want to recognize the difference
between true let's say taking on of sins
or the true uh
examining of yourself in order to see
you know the the good and evil going
through your own heart the difference
between that and weaponized compassion
seems to be exemplified in the story of
Judas when you see Judas
when the woman comes to pour the perfume
on Christ's feet Judas says you know you
should give that to the poor it's like
that's exactly that's exactly what we're
talking about in terms of you know you
know I I will care for the poor right
that's that's what I'll do but in the
story what's interesting is like it's
actually I will care for the poor rather
than worship the Divine you know worship
God and so she's actually worshiping the
son of man and he's saying you know you
should give to the poor but in in the
Scripture it says but what he was really
doing was taking the money for himself I
think that that's usually when you can
see it because you just have to watch
people who will want to uh let's say
accuse Christianity of all the sins and
you and then you just have to look a
little bit and realize that it's it's
actually a power play to take to to to
gain power for themselves there's
nothing authentic about it at all and
the the accuser well just a really
important point to make is that the
accuser is always
is never the truth yeah the accusation
is never the truth right because the
accuser in scripture and I I guess you
know in 2022 it can be weird for some
people that hear these two guys talking
about Satan or the satanic principle but
I mean Gerard identified the scapegoat
mechanism with
um sort of the spirit of Satan and what
is what is how is what are some of the
different ways that Satan is referred to
that Jesus refers to Satan in the
gospels the accuser right the father of
lies in a murderer since the beginning
so the accuser is always lying right
there's always there's always like some
some element of lie there it's not the
whole at the very least it's never the
whole truth yeah yeah it's it's very
easy to believe
um and I think that's where
that Spirit of accusation is what's
behind cancel culture and it's part of
my personal just and my personal
examination of conscience it's like how
am I being an accuser and how am I being
an advocate right The Advocate is
usually refers to the holy spirit in
scripture
um how who in my life is an accuser who
in my life as an advocate
um what in the culture is is operating
on the prince like literally gets power
from accusation because anything that
that derives power from accusation you
might say like all of Twitter is
basically like this hope Elon Musk can
solve that problem
um is is is certainly concerning to me
yeah
yeah yeah no you're right you're right
there's definitely something
and there's also the hip the hypocrisy
part of the accuser which I think cries
points out quite a bit in his ministry
you know where he sees the accusers in
terms of the the Pharisees and he says
that the accuser is often hiding his own
his own sin and uh and that in the case
of Judas that's definitely the case
whereas Judas is accusing the woman of
not caring for the poor when in fact you
know
he just wants power for himself
um and so there's definitely a lot of
that going on in terms of
in terms of the politics and also the
yeah even even in terms of of the the
fingers being pointed you know
yeah yeah and you know that's the story
of the woman caught in adultery is I
think the most memetically charged um
aside from the crucifixion in in the
gospels right it's just it's literally
there's a memetic process of accusation
that's taking place
um and it's defused by the only person
in the story this is the woman who's
caught in the act of adultery so we know
she's guilty right they drag her in
front of the temple in in the Gospel of
John
um you've got these Pharisees saying
she's guilty breaking the law of Moses
she deserves to be stoned and there's
this memetic process of contagion
everybody in the story is an accuser
except her and one other person and you
know Christ steps into the story as the
only person who stands outside of the
memetic processes the only person who's
not susceptible to them right
um one he's a Divine person
um and and free of sin so he's the only
in a sense most people don't think of
that story as as him defusing the
stoning
um as a miracle but if what Gerard is
saying it's true and that this is the
memetic process of violence that's been
operative it's the thing hidden since
the foundation of the world it's the way
that what humanity is always done you
could almost say that there's some kind
of divine intervention where the only
anti-memetic the only person not
participating
in the pattern of memetic contagion in
that story was Christ which is the only
reason he's able to defuse it and this
is the reason that people are really
scared to step in and stop we don't
really Stone people in this country
anymore but people are really scared to
step in and avert a cancel a
cancellation or something like that
because then they themselves get get
singled out right yeah and they nobody's
scared everybody just runs for the hills
when something like that happens so I've
often asked myself like we don't give
ourselves enough credit for having the
power to because sometimes it just takes
one person to be a subversive like break
in that process and and you know like in
the gospel story Christ totally reverses
it they drop their stones and walk away
and it's one of the beaut the reason
it's one of my favorite sort of stories
is because it's negative memetic
violence that's instantly transformed
into positive memetic desire or positive
like a positive form of Genesis because
it says the fir the elders starting with
the elders they drop their Stone models
of desire and then one by one the rest
of them left right so the elders dropped
the stones and the rest of them left you
know it's possible to actually affect
some positive contagion of of desire and
examination
yeah but it's difficult it's difficult
because we are caught up in the mimetic
desire ourselves and so we also
see that you know it's like the reason
why you're afraid of being canceled is
because you know you're not perfect
you've got you know everybody has things
that you look back and you're like oh
you know I'm not I definitely have sins
in my past so yeah it's difficult but
you're right there are some people that
seem to be able to
to do it and uh and when it happens it's
it's very powerful it's very beautiful
yeah well you're the you know it's I
don't know if the Observer problem is
the right way to talk about this but we
are ourselves it's weird talking about
mimesis and the medic desire and memetic
contagion because like at this very
moment I'm being affected by forces that
I probably don't even know right and I'm
very much like inside of the same story
that I'm talking about which makes all
of these
things
somewhat day I would even say dangerous
to talk you know not not to talk about
but like to to
pretend or to operate under the illusion
that we can achieve some kind of
permanent
um you know
um abstraction or removal from them
right like we're embedded in these
things and like one of the things I I I
hope that when I you know walk into go
in my Parish every Sunday like you know
for for an hour it sort of feels like
I'm you know I'm no longer in the world
right
um
and then within within one minute of
leaving I'm like you know yelling at the
guy who cut me off in the parking lot
right yeah yeah because I mean it's it's
like we're making this video we're gonna
put it on YouTube you know it's gonna
get likes it's gonna get comments it's
going to get shared these are the
mimetic these are all these mimetic
things that are on steroids right now in
terms of social media and so it's
definitely something that we're we're a
part of and it's difficult to pull like
you said it's difficult to pull
ourselves through
um and we kind of hope that the
Eucharist and you know participation in
the in the self-sacrifice of Christ if
we do it if we do it regularly and
properly that we it can somehow at least
like you said give us
a different perspective you know
yeah but then also noticing the times I
think like at least in my case I think
noticing although it like you said
sometimes it still is a memetic process
but noticing the times where I've been
able to just say give myself or
sacrifice some aspects of myself
for others and then seeing the fruits of
that you know it's like wow that works
like it's not just uh it actually really
does do something uh
but then that can also be that can also
become a medic competition you know if
you're not careful it's funny isn't it I
I um I spent a few years living in Rome
because I was in seminary studying
Theology and uh it's it's a it's an
alarming thing when you realize that the
guys
um that are participating in that
process of formation like start
competing
um on in in engaged in memetic rivalries
with each other in regards to like how
long they're in the chapel praying and
like who's praying on their knees and
who's not and stuff like that like it's
we can literally like anything can turn
into this you know if we're not aware of
it and if we're not original anything
can be like good right like I'm I'm here
trying to like make this sacrifice and
give of myself to the world and you know
grow and virtue and yet I can look to
you know my right and my left and and
get totally distracted from like what in
the hell I even came here for in the
first place yeah and you see I mean
Christ seems to be warning us about that
and they can help us understand some
things that Christ said and talks about
the importance of secret right the
importance of doing things in secret
because when you do things in secret If
You Give in secret or you pray in secret
or you you you you don't get the credit
for it
uh then it's actually a it it can be a
good healing mechanism or maybe a good
a good kind of position which you can
find yourself where you can now see you
know what's going on a little more
clearly because you're you're not
getting any not getting anything from
what you what you've done
uh so it's interesting to think about
yeah
listen I think this has been a great
this is great conversation uh I I
appreciate it we're having a a more
spiritual conversation that I then I was
uh I like that I I appreciate that thank
you all right so I will just send
everybody towards your towards your
towards your book it's called wanting
and uh it has great Peter Thiel gave it
a great review and and a lot of I was
really impressed to see how much how
much it's gotten positive reactions and
I think getting people to think about
these questions is important especially
with social media that acceleration of
social connection and the the
acceleration of contagions of these
types of contingents is so everything's
so fast now and it can happen so quickly
that unders at least understanding some
of the mechanisms is is useful for
everybody to understand
absolutely well thanks Jonathan I really
hope we can continue the conversation
sometime I appreciate it great yeah
thanks for coming on thanks